one of the things that's still uncertain
about covet 19
is how long immunity lasts that
information is important for vaccines
but also because it could help
scientists figure out when people can
become
re-infected immunologists believe the
percentage of re-infections is low
but knowing how many there are could be
important as the world looks to reopen
broadly a re-infection is when you get
sick from the disease
twice but for covid it's actually very
difficult to prove
because some people can be testing
positive a long time
after they first got sick so the
technical definition for coven 19
is if you get a reinfection that means
you got sick twice
but with two genetically different
strains of the virus
so to actually prove it the virus needs
to be genetically sequenced
each time so that the doctors can see
that you were infected
twice for real and not just testing
positive
from their first illness a couple months
later
so there isn't much being done to track
coverage infection
particularly in the u.s without actually
doing the sequencing it's impossible to
know
how many reinfections are happening we
don't have a lot of resources for
genetic sequencing
a lot of the doctors and hospitals are
really overwhelmed trying to take care
of sick people and they're not really
taking the time to do genetic sequencing
some hospitals don't even have the
capabilities for it
and even if a doctor does do the
sequencing and says oh this is actually
a reinfection
there's no one to report it to you
there's no central database of cova 19
reinfections yet
some countries are doing a lot better
than us countries like australia and
thailand are sequencing
a lot of their cases but even then
reinfection isn't a metric that's being
tracked very much right now
and that's a problem it's a private
scientist of real world examples of how
long immunity lasts
examples that could help with the
problem of newer more contagious
variants we don't know if people who are
getting re-infected
are getting reinfected with these new
variants or not and some of these
variants are more contagious and
potentially even more deadly
and so it's really important that we
keep track of these variants and without
keeping track of reinfections we're not
doing all we can
to really make sure we're capturing all
these variants and we know that some of
the vaccines
are less effective against some of these
variants too so it's really important
that we know how many cases are actually
occurring because of these new variants
i think one thing that's important to
note is that there have been
thousands of re-infections but the
number of reinfections is still very
small compared to the number of
new coronavirus infections so i think
the most important thing is stopping new
coronavirus infections
because if you never get it you can
never be reinfected
you